the beauty about not theory is it's sort
of a special subfield of mathematics
where you don't have to know much
mathematics you don't need to know a lot
about numbers you don't need to know
about differential stuff no integration
no matrices it's a branch of mathematics
can pick up from scratch all by itself
and actually come up with interesting
results and understand what's going on
people then often ask what about not is
there something practical i cannot think
of something that's really practical in
the terms of shoelaces or so when they
still believed that our universe is
filled with some ether ether was that
medium that would transport you know
light waves and so on and then i think
it was lord kelvin and others that
believed that the atoms are just
different knots so the simplest possible
atoms say hydrogen maybe just the unknot
and then maybe helium is the next more
complicated knot and so that's the
trefoil knot and then you go down the
periodic system and of course it was a
beautiful and tempting way of bringing
order into the periodic table except it
was just plain wrong i mean pretty soon
people found out there is no ether and
of course also people found that
actually atoms break apart into into
particles in some way there's more
structure to it and they're clearly not
not they're more more like little
planetary system and so that was the end
of that on the other hand knots actually
now play a role in advanced physics
in advanced chemistry and in advanced
biology your own physics you know even
with string theory and and similar
things they're even in statistical
mechanics that suddenly they use some of
the things they could prove is not that
seem to apply there in chemistry they're
now building molecules that are
deliberately knotted in complicated ways
they're also people working with
nanoparticles that seem to find
materials that have interesting
properties when you know the elementary
elements
at the small scale are knotted and
finally in biology you probably have
millions of knots in your body it turns
out many bacteria but even in your cell
some of the dna strands are actually
closed loops and some of them are
actually happen to be knotted if you
have some a closed dna strand that may
be knotted and you can see in this case
there may be a particular group exposed
and it can undergo some chemical
interaction with other molecules but
then if this thing kind of folds up in
different way
that part may no longer be available but
something else may pop out and then that
can interact so as part of the
regulation of what goes on inside a cell
some of these strands may recoil and and
change their shape and turns out they
even can change their knottedness
because there actually are some enzymes
and these enzymes they can essentially
come along and snip the strand and
essentially let another strand pass
through and then reconnect it something
of course mathematicians would never do
because that that's totally against what
you're allowed to do in not theory so
that's where knots play a role in very
advanced fields i have three challenges
for you here typically the kind of
exercises you want to do when you get
started with not theory is you look at
something that you might draw
arbitrarily you know having over and
under crossings in some way and then the
question is what not is this and now you
may want to go and take your
pipe cleaners or wires and try to
carefully lay out this particular knot
this over and under crossings carefully
observed
fuse the ends together
and now the question is
okay which knot is it if i'm just
counting here it's going to be one two
three four crossing so you think oh must
be the four crossing not must be the
figure eight not true or not true
let's take this loop that's of hangs
down and just kind of flip it up right
so now somehow this thing goes up there
makes a loop and comes back down and
then goes into this knot this loop up
there can be untwisted and it goes away
but then what just left is this part
with this closing back onto itself and
we know what that is that's a trefoil
so here you see an example where you
have something that looks slightly more
complicated
it's relatively easy to unravel this and
figure out okay this is just a trefoil
knot well things can get worse what not
is this now yeah you can do a lot of
mental exercise i think i could take
this whole loop and kind of flip it over
and then i can actually pull it through
here and similarly i can take this loop
here and flip it around the back to the
other side i'm pretty sure that this
knot will get simpler when you try to
unravel it i think you should really lay
this out try it with some wire or pipe
clean and figure out
what knot it is oh you're making people
do a lot of homework all right go on
now more difficult homework here is yet
another knot one two three four five six
six crossings no problem i mean i can
try to mentally flip these loops around
or so and
nothing comes of it so i'm probably
stuck now i go back to the not table
that we had before can we figure out
this six crossing knot which one of
those three it is and you may want to do
a lot of deforming you probably will get
very frustrated because you may not be
able to find anything and he said wait a
minute
is there a fourth different kind of not
not really
mathematicians call this a composite
knot it's really two trefoil knots stuck
together you can see from here to there
it's clearly a trefoil knot and we can
take this loop and kind of flip it down
and then we'd have another trifold knot
and it's coupled to this one with these
two links so anytime you can take one
complicated knot and cut it open
somewhere so two strands stick out
another complicated knot cut it open
some are two strands stick out you put
them together you essentially get
a compound knot
and that's not its own not it's that's
like doesn't fit into a table of well it
would make things much much more
complicated so this allows to simplify
things
now all of the knots that you see in
here are called prime knots
they cannot possibly be reduced to
something simpler
they're really on their own as
complicated as they get but there are
many many complicated knots that can be
taken apart like a complicated number
can be taken apart into prime factors
but once you have a prime factor you can
no further simplify it so all the not
table does is give you only prime knots
that are not themselves compound but now
you can take 7 3 and take you know six
three snip it open here sneak it open
there stick them together and you make
something that has on the order of seven
plus six crossings but it's not a 13
crossing knot it's it's this compound
knot kept that a secret i feel like
you've dropped a bomb on me
so if you didn't do that you know then
the knot table would become totally
unwieldy okay now it would explode even
even more quickly and even faster
you actually are on the other side and
then you have to go once through more
through the roller coaster until you
come back to where you start it
so it's just one long string you know
essentially tied together